- [Voiceover] As we exit
1917 and enter into 1918,
we're getting into the
final stages of World War I.
And let's just give ourselves
a little bit of review,
a little bit of background,
a little bit of context.
The war started off as
a two-front war for the Central Powers.
You have the Western Front,
you have the Western
Front right over here,
and you had the huge,
you had the huge Eastern
Front right over here.
By 1917, the major conflict
on the Eastern Front,
especially with Russia, which
was the major power there,
had come to an end.
You had a February Revolution in Russia.
The czar had to abdicate the throne.
You had a provisional government.
Then in November of 1917,
the Bolsheviks have a
coup, they take over.
They have no interest in
prosecuting World War I,
because they have their own
civil war to worry about,
so they sign an armistice
with the Central Powers,
by the end of 1917.
And then we get into 1918,
just let me write all this down,
so by the time we get into 1918,
they're ready to sign a treaty in March,
in March, the Russians sign
the Treaty of Brest-Litovsk,
Litovsk,
which cedes over all of this
territory to the Germans
and takes the Russians out of World War I.
So I'm not gonna, I've gone
into detail in other videos,
but a huge amount of territory,
and I'm gonna do it very
informally right over here.
I'll give a rough sense of
where that territory was.
And the treaty itself,
its main significance,
'cause the treaty didn't last,
as you might already know,
the Central Powers lost World War I,
so that treaty was later nullified.
But the key importance of that treaty,
is one, it took Russia out of the war,
it allowed the Central
Powers, especially Germany,
to focus on the Western Front.
But the other element of it is,
by giving so much
territory to the Germans,
the Germans couldn't just
leave that territory as is.
If they wanted any claims to it,
they had to devote some
of their troops to occupy,
or at least attempt to occupy some of it.
So even though it was a huge opportunity,
and the Germans were able
to, after the treaty,
or even before the treaty,
after the armistice,
they were able to start bringing many more
of the Eastern-Front troops
over to the Western Front.
They didn't bring over as
many as they could have,
because they left some
to attempt to occupy
some of the territory that had been gained
on the Eastern Front.
But if you view things
from a German perspective,
at this point, March 1918,
you're gonna be feeling pretty good.
You are holding your own
in a two-front war now,
and at one point you thought Russia
was the major threat there.
That threat is gone, you can
now focus on a one-front war,
maybe you should be able to kind of
put the decisive blow
against the allies now.
And that is how the Germans felt.
But they were worried
about a couple of things.
They were worried about the
British industrial capacity,
and the Allied industrial capacity,
that was stronger than the Central Powers,
and so the British
could produce more tanks
and more guns and more weapons,
so it was a race against that,
and there was also a race against
significant American entry.
Remember, April 1917,
Woodrow Wilson gives a speech to Congress,
they declare war on the Central Powers,
and so the Germans wanna
get this thing over with
before the Americans have a chance
to send in significant
number of fresh troops.
So in March 1918, not only do you have
the Treaty of Brest-Litovsk,
you also have the beginning
of Germany's attempt
to deal that decisive blow to the Allies,
and it's known as the Spring Offensive.
So you have the Spring,
the Spring Offensive.
And the goal of the Spring Offensive
was to essentially try to
end the war for the Germans.
And the goal was to separate
the British from the French forces.
The British, for the most
part, were in control
of the line right over here,
north of the Salm River,
while the French were
in control south of it.
So the Spring Offensive,
especially the first phases
of the Spring Offensive, in March 1918,
focused on this area, right over here.
And at first it was
actually very successful.
They were able to make
huge territorial gains,
drive through the lines,
drive the Allied Powers back.
Now, the problem was is that it wasn't
a real big strategic gain.
The Germans were just hoping
it would be such a demoralizer,
that it would throw at least,
maybe the French out of the war,
and then maybe they could
take care of the British
or whatever else, but that didn't happen,
and all of a sudden they found themselves
with these huge territorial gains,
in very short amount of time,
they had to supply themselves,
and they didn't really quite,
and they had spread their troops thin,
and so it frankly just
let the opportunity arise
for the Allies, in August,
to lead a counteroffensive.
And this counteroffensive by the Allies,
is referred to as the 100 Days Offensive.
It began in August, went
roughly into November,
so 100 Days, 100 Days Offensive,
during which the Allies,
between August and November,
were able to push the
Germans, not only back
beyond what they had captured
during the Spring Offensive,
but all the way well back of the front
that was kind of the stalemate line
for most of World War I.
And it was during this 100 Days Offensive,
that to most objective observers,
it was clear that the
Allies would win this war.
And it was clear to several
of the Central Powers,
or those Allied with the Central Powers.
As we go into September,
as we go into September of 1918,
Bulgaria drops itself out of the war,
just to remind ourselves where,
what we're talking about.
So you have Bulgaria right over here.
It, Bulgaria, right over here.
It signs an armistice with the Allies,
so, let me just, you have armistice,
I'll use a little peace
symbol for armistice,
that's a, armistice is just
the fighting has stopped,
you still, in theory,
could be at a state of war,
so maybe I shouldn't do the peace symbol,
I'll just write armistice.
Armistice, Armistice, with Bulgaria.
And this is really starting
to tighten the noose
around the remaining Central Powers,
because this allowed the
Allies to gain control
of Serbia and of Greece,
which essentially tied,
removed the last source of food
for Austria, Hungary
and the German Empire.
There was already a blockade,
the kind of the harsh, British blockade
that we've already talked
about, up in the North Sea,
and so their last source
of food was from the south,
but now with Bulgaria
signing an armistice,
and ceding over territory,
now the strangle hold was really,
was really, really coming into effect.
Now, by October, and remember,
at this point it was reasonably clear,
and even by this point, even
clear to the German people
that the war is pretty much done for,
and they're just waiting for their leaders
to make it official.
So several of the leaders
of the German Navy
wanted to do this last-ditch,
what could easily be considered suicidal,
offensive against the British Navy,
and as they're planning it and
the sailors catch wind of it,
they mutiny, they revolt.
They say hey, look, the war is over.
We're not gonna die in a futile attempt
to just kind of, for
pride or whatever else,
and so you have a naval mutiny begins.
Naval mutiny, and eventually
this spreads to the mainland
and leads to revolts and revolutions,
so revolution in Germany, in Germany.
And this culminates in
November, in November,
November 9th, famous date in history,
November 9th, 1918.
You essentially, Kaiser Wilhelm II,
right over here, let me make
sure you see his picture,
this is him right over
here, Kaiser Wilhelm II,
is forced to abdicate, give up his throne.
He flees to the Netherlands,
and on November 9th, 1918,
Germany is declared a republic.
So Germany no longer has a
king or emperor in charge.
Germany becomes a republic.
And a little bit before
this, November 3rd,
the writing was already
clear to the Austrians,
in fact, they even, in 1917,
attempted to make some peace overtures,
thinking that they were
pretty much done for,
but by November 3rd, 1918,
the Austrians also signed an armistice,
armistice, armistice,
with the Austrians, with the Austrians,
and with the Kaiser Wilhelm
II fleeing to the Netherlands,
Germany becoming a republic,
this sets up the armistice,
finally, with Germany
on November 11th,
and this is one of the most
famous dates in history,
known for a long time in
the US as Armistice Day,
and so it was November 11th, 1918,
and it was actually 11am, 11am,
so you might remember the famous,
the 11th hour of the 11th
day of the 11th month,
war, or World War I, or the
fighting in World War I,
was over with the Allies victorious,
and the Central Powers losing it,
and the terms of what would
happen for those that lost
and those that won would be dictated
by the Treaty of Versailles.
The Treaty of Versailles in 1919.
The terms of which were finally finalized
about six months later.
So this is June, you have the treaty,
Treaty of, Treaty of,
Treaty of Versailles.
Which, incidentally,
this is like one of those
little footnotes in history,
the Americans did not actually ratify it,
mainly because it had the
League of Nations in it,
which was this project of Woodrow Wilson,
but the American people
and the American Congress
was not a fan of this whole
trans-national government,
League of Nations thing,
so the United States did not
ratify the Treaty of Versailles
but in effect, on Armistice
Day, November 11th, 11am,
the war was over, Treaty of
Versailles dictated the terms,
many would argue, overly-harsh terms,
of the Treaty of Versailles,
and we're done with World War I.